sabes garantem esquina e não tem esquina
e eu também disse no programa da
figueira antonio fica três anos o tempo
visto que estudam o assunto pessoal de
quem falou dar que sejam muito bem
vindos
é mais um e mostrar que sei que é nossa
primeira gameplay do para quem não viu o
vídeo solo construída a cantora jullie
firefox podem encontrar no jogo portanto
é se tornar o vídeo google muito bem ou
talvez porque eu não conhecia antes
disso já não se interessa por que então
eu só tenho uma coisa a fazer que é
colocar mais vidas pra vcs que dela mas
eu preciso fazer deixei muito aqui nos
filhos que quiserem ver mais frio ainda
que no canal esta vai ser minha primeira
gameplay bom essa é minha personagem
ainda fato poderosa mas o meu cãozinho
só no caso indo pra quem não sabe este é
o uso que só poderia ter uso que nem
para quem nenhum tipo pessoal a minha
primeira vez aqui no free fire não é bem
a primeira vez aqui porque já joguei
também há imenso tempo atrás no méxico
ultimamente tem estado que ela fique
mobile e pude então já não tem jogado
muito ovo frito vamos lá ver no que vai
dar porque mecânica é completamente
diferente vocês passarem agora trocar o
flu que vocês vão ver que mecânica é
outra eu pedi um call of duty e o frei
faz um som completamente diferente na
jogabilidade aqui para correr eu tenho
que ganhar aqui ó pois ela cosmo e nunca
o futuro no clube não é tipo é só
restaram dele ela vai portanto tem uma
vitória agora atravessou gesto no meu
aqui é o 1
vocês vão presenciar o méxico levar fama
não dar prêmios ou amigos ou pior ainda
tem muita gente aí e vamos tentar
afastar aqui do pessoal porque eu acho
que essa estratégia já aquele que um
indivíduo este é o inimigo é o nosso
primeiro inimigo mas ambientes natal eu
estou a pensar em ficar em primeiro mas
esse é só um pensamento né
isso não quer dizer que vai acontecer
vamos lá ver o que está aqui o inimigo
foge da aneel foi para aquela casa então
vamos lá
isto mesmo por cima de ti meu amigo e
agora e agora nada porque eu tô sem arma
vai começar muito mal tá muito poder a
gente transmite já passei por isso meu
deus
selma peixe cada magnífica que vai dar a
ele um lado eu quero uma fofoquinha arma
lá lá que é pior com jogos turma está
uma intenção eu não sei se vocês também
são assim mas sempre que vejo algum
inimigo e eu estou sem arma daquela
omissão no coração no art meu primeiro
gol
não é que não deixem em paz uma obra
solitária sair daqui no ar foi embora
jovem joga pior que usa só vocês já
viram algum em outubro os campeões do
que eu digo mãe nos comentários que
perceber que há períodos em que vem mas
agora é chef mara mac não sei qual é o
que é uma 3081 normal acalmar que não
seja burro burro ou tem árvores nas
árvores
as obras na china pela na china avançou
que no chão em um cofre foi do staff as
leis do da natureza oito previam a tv
armas possa consumir mais medicamentos
para ficar agilizado a assumir assumir a
subida é será que se eu te parar naquela
hora não acontece nada é que nenhuma
cimento nada nada só eu não vou perder
tempo a explicar o jogo porque 99% você
já deve ter jogado fifa e começa o jogo
mais do que eu provavelmente por um
morcego não te deixes vai ela os
cemitérios acreditar que ela estava indo
eu nem vou perder tempo a explicar o
jogo por vocês já sabem né então eu
preciso das vossas de judas mais um dos
símbolos do diabo
agora estou possuído müssnich tem o
rosto diabo no corpo ano está melhor
eu acho que o é maior é maior e melhor é
uma pena o vento por filipe 90
eu não sei se vocês são como eu mas
neste jogo tá naquela emoção que se vem
alguém atrás de mim com uma pistola para
fim alguém para me matar eu fico furioso
que matar as duas voltas o furioso e
nunca se pensava então um tem que
escolher quando ele tentava matar
só que ao mesmo tempo não quer matar eu
quero fugir será que existe um predador
é que nestes campos ao menos porque eu
só que daqui não dá é que nem dá
patrocinam pesca lages week valor no
primeiro andar
vamos lá ver o mapa eu tenho que andar
mais ou menos pra que eu nestes jogos
gosto sempre de apontar o maior que já
viu né
lajotas porém a sujeito aqui eu voltar
dilma só ele é e tem por mim ali um
indivíduo embaixo e eu tentava fugir
olha coelho eo preço o hélio é legal eu
vou apanhar carregava isso espera como
não tenho mais nada porque não tive uma
chance na equipe e vamos entender não é
ter uma cidade por mall eu vou me
aproximar preciso que eu sou eu sou
buscarei tentam salvar cerca
eu vou me matar coelho calma isso
garantem esquina eu tenho aqui no rio
também tem aqui no botafogo não fica
atrás
o tcu bispos que estão no filme thomas
menino para o planeta e tomem a outro
ensina o trombini eye moviment isso aqui
é um caso cometam o dia sol e não chove
an a opel pela costa paraná
tinhas matar quem é vinhos meta ganhar
pois é dar frames do evento foi rafael
em nossa campanha e eu nem tinha que
aparecer meus amigos mais medicamentos
bonito da plenitude foch gostinho de uma
capa é a capa que ocorre agora
e agora é que vai ser sou [ __ ] dez
livros agora é só profissionais é só
para o flash não os a itown o alarme
tocar olha só como é que eu vou as
pessoas lá em cima
toda explosões nuno cunha é o sujeito
que o deus desta mira telegráfica com um
temperaturas
ai ai ai eu não tem mais um sujeito não
tenho arma dela mas que há uma caixa que
cruza muito tento e igor é eu hoje não
ver a onda tabosa calma esta aqui e isso
e agora estou aqui
não não rapaz o que ataca as
concentrações com esse trecho que dá uma
chance e fui pra longe acabou já ninguém
vai pra cima e é isso que eu estava
falando do solo quer fugir solo vezes
quebra no combate ao desmatamento é
preciso ficar ali parava o morro esta
técnica pra ninguém vai dar flamengo é
um baixo
a china fechou tem muita curva está aqui
numa selva tem que ver isso tudo
vermelho o que eu tenho pra zona
qualquer
só faltam quatro têm três pessoas olha
pra mim eles querem aprender a jogar
como eu né acreano criou novos vão
ensinar a cuidar vai andar a bater tá né
se o palhaço só dois somam com 2.000
deus se eu ganhar este jogo a primeira
eu sou incrivelmente do fantástico forte
poderoso indjai do prefeito eu nem vou
ver o que é que eu tenho dentro da
mochila porque não é
já tenho essas posses comigo dentro do
meu bolso
filha de mãe eu fiz campanha aí estava
quase matou o então cônsul matá lo eu
fui muito incluindo colocou pelo jeito
pra não morrer palhaço seu prazo dos
ares mais que outros as barreiras hoje
não vá ali no canto eo luto também é aí
que possui uma coisa tinha uma caixa
olha que bom
aí eu também tem isto eu vou usar trata
de vôos a estreita disse eu vou falar
aqui isso estudar tudo isso muito tomate
aí a nossa caixa e este site está muito
intenso
eu estava nas bombas fim do fim de um
pêssego aí manhã de camané ou e ela é
que vai ganhar aí o que aí ativo só eu e
outro gol eu o outro eu fui apanhado por
2 a 1
eu não merecia morrer eu não não sexual
só comenta e mas o que acabou meu que
entrego eu ia ganhar este jogo não foi
desta que vamos fazer outro jogo e vamos
lá ver como corre para votar na av
será que eu consigo kanaan não consegui
olha a água é assim é que eu vou te
encontrar uma arma a mais é um choque é
nem uma só tacada em todas o tucano
falou deverá se instalar mas transitam
na garagem encontrar acima do país
depois começar a fala meu deus vj
construção está muito grande porque
muita coisa aqui dentro muita imensa a
gente aqui já vou tentar aprender o
máximo que eu puder aqui fora porque sim
voador centro de acolhimento a a acho
que é perigoso aqui dentro eu vou riscar
o euro subir
eu vou subir em um chute de gum tirou da
prova e as coisas aqui o vovô japão
nesta
turíbio se estão que é uma mina ou não
consigo
op chutar é ó a pena que meu futuro a
tardeo otários em morcego navas
dependurado é a tiros quando nunca lá em
cima por ciúme jemusse e gushiken somos
cegos onde está o fundo volta
olha o morcego preciso não temer o
palhaço
serrana preço mas curar e para a causa
mas agora não tem balas
ele tem um shot gun n me choca é né da
palhaço ainda cafona baixo ou não para a
rim bold é e eu parti um pelo chão bem
um puro não sou muito boa a culpa foi
minha não olha catuca turra tuca 69
coisa melhor prato e se imprescindível a
um homem cujo matou um homem a um tiro
na parede com ela frente meu né o kaká
toca tudo é burra final enfim acho que
tá bom groso já deixou passar vergonha
e aí só se vocês quiserem ver mais frio
ainda que no canal ou vídeos deste
gênero como cabo frio e mobile para
dilma lá eu comentei também perceber
isso não esqueçam deixa muito aqui no
espírito fiquem bem até apróxima que não
está cá tom olho com isto eu tenho ainda
escolha o fato que eu quero um hackathon
ainda tem índice polônia ficou um homem
vai trazê lo
bem feita católica podre está solapando
januário não está ao menos cavadas
já agora josé trair o voto direto e
outra para ter o cabelo a